now from senior political analyst brit
hume good evening britt you know getting
ahead of this one-on-one meeting between
president biden and
vladimir putin it is a shift as peter
mentioned
worthy adversary bright uh from
calling him a killer what about this
setup
well donald trump would never have said
anything like that about putin
really i mean he didn't like to
criticize putin
biden has and he's also praised him as
we heard in those remarks that
that peter ducey peter ducey cited and
and that you heard from from biden
himself
um so everything has kind of been
overshadowed i think brett by the
anticipation of this wednesday meeting
and you know i don't think you have any
real idea about what's going to come out
of it
um biden is at times talk tough and then
you hear him say he doesn't want
conflict um
it's hard for me to imagine how on the
path that russia's on
there wouldn't be conflict i don't mean
armed conflict but conflict
and it there's nothing that came out of
the actions uh taken by the
by the g7 or out of this nato meeting
uh the concrete actions that tell us
very much about where this whole issue
is going both against china and against
russia yeah you and i have covered a lot
of these multilateral conferences and
get-togethers and
um this was especially seemed watered
down when it came to russia and china
yeah i guess the big moment for
everybody in europe is that biden is now
once again
citing the significance and importance
of nato which is after all the most
successful military alliance probably in
history
um but one thing that should be noted
about these alliances with lots and lots
of countries in them that when you're
trying to take
actual action um you got everybody got
to get everybody on board and
not everybody is always on board and
europe has a long history
uh during the cold war of being you know
hesitant more hesitant than the united
states was
and leaving it to the united states to
carry the burden of
military action if it were required or
the placement of troops or whatever
because because europe is hesitant so
you know that may be biden's opportunity
um as the newly uh
readmitted member in good standing of
the
club of of national leaders there but um
but it becomes a burden as well as
as i've noted yeah some european leaders
said uh privately that kind of like the
boring g7s
better but let me at the end of the g7
there was this press conference with
president biden
over the weekend and uh and there was a
moment that caught people's attention
in what she was trying to talk about
syria and specific
policy in syria take a listen
we could work together with russia for
example
in libya and for example
the rebuilding of of syria
of uh of libya so i'm hopeful
that we can find an accommodation
that where we can save the lives of
people in for example
in in libya your thoughts about that
well obviously brett this is another one
of these episodes of which there have
been
quite a number in which the president
forgot something
uh he confused libya and syria he
confuses things with some regularity and
and in public
and it raises anew the question of
whether really his age
um when forgetfulness is an
understandable and
and not at all uncommon uh issue
um is is makes him not
necessarily the in the best position to
act as president
you know you got to get up on the world
stage and not confuse your countries
so this is something that some of us way
back in 2016 during the campaign warned
about
there was a lot of scoffing at it and a
kind of a refusal of the mainstream
media to even cover it
but now it's out there in the you know
out there in the open i don't think
there's anywhere around it there it is
brett as always thank you hey sean
hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else